it sounds like Nintendo could be
entering the movie business according to
recent comments from CEO tatsumi
kimishima an interview with japanese
publication the Asahi Shimbun as
translated by Col MacLean on Twitter
sites kimishima explaining that Nintendo
will release a new movie in the next two
to three years and the publisher is
interested in a production system where
they can do as much as they can
themselves producing the film's
internally could comfort fans who want
to see the film stay true to Nintendo's
franchises and characters Ubisoft is
doing much the same thing with their
Ubisoft motion pictures division which
is behind the upcoming Assassin's Creed
movie in February of this year Shigeru
Miyamoto stated Nintendo's role as an
entertainment company saying that they
were considering bringing their
franchises to film in the future we
don't know what sort of Nintendo movies
were in for as yet but as long as
they're a far cry from the critically
panned super mario brothers live action
movie I think we can all breathe a sigh
of relief let me know in the comments
what Nintendo franchise you'd like to
see hit the big screen and we'll keep
you updated on this one on gamespot